like his family owns the New York
Football Giants his dad's nickname is on
the football the son of the Duke John
Mara joining me here on the Rich Eisen
show my condolences on the passing of
Frank effort to you sir
thank you very much rich it was it said
that for all this year so what's your
first memory of Frank Gifford yeah for
me it was probably five or six years old
just going to our training camp and meet
him for the first time and he was a
larger-than-life figure for me and
somebody that I idolized right away and
like many kids who grew up in my
generation and we all wanted to be even
like email or Frank Gifford and just
seeing him running onto the field at
Yankee Stadium and then blue number 16
was image that I always have that's in
my mind you know he was a great player
for us a great ambassador for us and a
great representative of the National
Football League for so many years you
called him the ultimate Giants what do
you mean by that
I mean I think you could make the case
that he was the most important player in
the history of our franchise I mean came
along at a time 1952 where the NFL was
really struggling as a weak attractive
fans and gain recognition and and all of
a sudden we have a tremendous string of
successful seasons in the late 1950s and
he was the star of that team the most
recognizable player on that to you the
matinee idol the one player that
everybody idolized and what do you
lacking we rose to prominence I stood
professional football during that period
in the late 50s and early 60s and all of
a sudden our team is selling out every
Sunday something and it continues to
this day and and a lot of that is
attributable to the player like Frank
Gifford that came along during that era
I'm on the phone with the Giants owner
John Merrow here on the Rich Eisen show
your father and Frank Gifford were
inducted in the Pro Football Hall of
Fame 20 years apart
77 for gifford 97 for your dad and they
presented each other what was their
relationship like it was a father-son
relationship almost right from the
beginning and my father scouted and
drafted Franken in 1952 and they
immediately developed a close bond that
lasted for the rest of their lives and
he was always at the family function the
he wrote our home games with my mother
and sisters every Sunday and it was
always around but they had a special
relationship in good times and in bad
and he was always there for my father
and vice versa and it was a special bond
unlike you know with any other player
and owner that I've seen anyway the two
of them were very close and as I said I
think it was this close to a father-son
relationship as anything if Frank had
the chance to see your dad last night
which we assume he did what do you think
that conversation was like John you know
I think they they would have embraced
and talked about all times and told each
other how much they care for one another
because I was something that they did in
life and I'm sure that's going to
continue up there as well it was just it
was a very special relationship that he
had with my dad and with our entire
family now it's it because we all take
for granted now that players are on TV
selling stuff and being in front of the
camera my gosh it seemed half your team
was selling five-dollar footlongs about
it you know the last 10 years John but
it was Frank the first one to do that in
the NFL do you think I don't know I
don't know if he was actually the first
that he was the first one that people
remember he's certainly the first one
that I remember I mean he was doing it
while he was a player and you know he
moved right into it when his playing
career ended you know we do the sports
on the news on channel 2 CBS and then he
was in the CBS a broadcast booth for
four games and he did it at a very early
age and I think you really set the trend
for other players to move into
broadcasting and you know he did it with
such ease and grace he really
quite a high standard for it but he's
the first one that most of us remember
doing this yeah and then he and some are
all are really the best ever going from
playing to a play-by-play position
normally the players obviously are the
analysts I don't think we're gonna ever
see another group like that again
Jonathan I think you're probably right
about that and you need skill Frankie to
do the play-by-play as well as anybody
and it could be an analyst as well as
anybody in conduct interviews and just
look at the events he covered around the
world I mean from you know Olympics to
alpine skiing to you know swimming and
diving I mean he did it all and he was a
real professional now I know this
happened just 24 hours ago are there any
discussions right now about the Giants
doing something in his honor for the
season yeah we're talking about that
right now but I'm sure we'll do
something in the forum but we haven't
finalized any plans as it okay before I
let you go I'd be remiss if I didn't ask
you about what you're doing in Chicago
and in front of you and the membership
our presentations about football
returning to where I am right now
Southern California what are you
expecting to hear at this meeting in
Chicago I think the purpose is to just
get an update from the sorties that are
expressed interest in moving there and
from the cities that that are involved
and striving to keep those teams and
it's just an effort to bring all the
owners up to date with whatever progress
has been made and where everybody stands
it's more of a informational session
anything else no vote is expected to be
taken but this is just a meeting to try
to update everybody on whatever progress
has been made
now folks around here in Southern
California say this has a different feel
than in previous years where there was a
discussion that seemed like we were
close to football returning to the Los
Angeles area that it feels different
would you agree with that assessment I
would definitely agree with that and
I've said before that I would be very
surprised if there was not one team if
not two teams playing in Los Angeles as
early as next season and before I again
thank you for calling in I wanted
hit you quickly on Jason pierre-paul
John you were the only owner I've ever
heard ever wonder how many fingers a
player has and I'm not saying this
facetiously when I asked do you know
right now how many fingers Jason
pierre-paul has John now I mean and I
wasn't trying to be flippant no I know
that I don't respond yeah no I was
responding to a question about you know
whether we expected him back and when
did we expect him back and and we just
don't know the condition of his hand
right now because our medical people
have not seen it so until we get a
chance to look at him it's hard to make
any assessment about that so how would
you characterize the team's relationship
with him right now oh it's a good
relationship with him listen we all feel
terrible for the young man he's one of
those popular players on our team
everybody likes Jason pierre-paul he's
you know a pleasure to be around and we
still have a good relationship with him
but you know he's decided that you need
to stay down in Florida until he's ready
to come up here and do some therapy so
that's his right to do that we'd rather
have him up with us but but that's what
decision is made and lastly if you want
to leave him a thought in people's minds
about Frank Gifford what would you want
people who are there different
generations my generation I remember him
from his initial Monday night football
both my my colleagues here on the set
remember him and the later years of the
Monday Night Football booth you
obviously know him from his playing days
how would you like to leave the thought
of Frank Gifford in people's minds
I find it was the consummate
professional
the ultimate giant but more importantly
one of the most decent men that I've
ever met
and somebody that you know we all
aspired to be life because he conducted
in software such class and indie
surround his wife John thanks for
calling in I truly appreciate it thank
you thanks thanks for you bet that's
John Merrow
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience